TERRY BRADSHAW: If I could do
anything in my life,
if God says, "Terry,
I'm gonna start you over,
what would you do?"
This is what I'd do.
HOST:
Please welcome to the stage,
the one, the only,
-Terry Bradshaw!
-(AUDIENCE CHEERS, APPLAUDS)
-How you doin'?
-♪ (ROCK AND ROLL MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
This is the story
about my NFL career and life.
When I was born in 1948,
God made me a football player.
And he gave me a strong arm.
I liked to throw
that sucker deep.
The Steelers select
Terry Bradshaw,
quarterback, Louisiana Tech.
-COMMENTATOR: Here's Bradshaw.
-COMMENTATOR 2: Touchdown!
COMMENTATOR 3:
Swann makes a perfect catch
in the end zone.
Winning the Championship
was the key.
COMMENTATOR 4:
The Pittsburgh Steelers
are the champions
of the National Football League
for the fourth time!
Whoo!
TERRY:
As much as we accomplished,
it was hard to enjoy.
TERRY: (SINGING)
♪ Before I reach the end zone ♪
♪ Before my final goal ♪
(CHUCKLES) As you can imagine,
God knows
I've had a lot of therapy.
-(CHEERING)
-(LAUGHTER)
Let's go!
♪ (COUNTRY AND WESTERN MUSIC
PLAYS) ♪
TERRY:
It's just been an amazing life.
Really, truly been
an amazing life.
♪ I'm going deep ♪
-(AUDIENCE CHEERS, APPLAUDS)
-TERRY: Oh yeah!
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪
(AUDIENCE APPLAUDS)